[Musique]
il est toujours ça les montées bas ce
matin il faisait la gueule en tout cas
mais du coup je pige pas il s'est passé
un truc entre vous c'est la seconde
avant avec valentine et là on peut
laisser tout seul mais c'était pour des
bonnes raisons
du coup j'aurais bien demander
d'expliquer l'expression être salée vu
qu'il est en plus ils auraient bien du
geste rêver il voudra jamais quoi hier
il m'a presque forcé à participer à sa
collaboration
c'était perturbant les agneaux l'heure
est grave
d'ici la fin du siècle le niveau de la
mer sera monté d'un à trois mètres 280
millions de réfugiés climatiques seront
chassés de leurs demeures côtière
des villes entières seront rayés de la
carte adieu bangkok new york miami rio
et palavas les flots
heureusement pour vous j'ai la solution
à ce problème je suis hyper docteur
internationale en biotechnologie neuro
quantique à boucles et voici mon verdict
il faut nous rendre résistant au sel
comme ça on pourra vivre les pieds dans
l'eau une rotule en l'air comme les
flamands c'est chic ou mieux on
construira des villes sous marine une
atlantide 2.0 et pour ce faire on va
s'inspirer du vivant qui est un
incubateur d'innovation depuis trois
milliards et demi d'années
ensemble construisons un monde à l'eau
tolérant aller en selle merci d'avoir
acheté ma formation pour faire de vous
un être résistant au sel
vous avez raison de me faire confiance
le vrai problème outre le capitalisme
c'est que le sel est un cadeau
empoisonné
un poison nécessaires à la vie un poison
parce que si vous en mangez 25 grammes
d'un coup mais quatre cuillères à soupe
vous mourrez de déshydratation le sel
est aussi un facteur de risque
d'hypertension artérielle de maladies
cardiovasculaires et de cancer de
l'estomac
il peut aussi favoriser l'ostéoporose
mais attention pas le seul en soi
l'excès de capitalisme c'est si on
dépasse 5 grammes par jour ce qu'on fait
allègrement tout le temps d'après
l'organisation mondiale de la santé la
plupart des gens consomment 9 à 12
grammes de sel par jour en moyenne donc
le double de l'apport maximum
l'hélice busset qui sommeille en nous a
envie de tout de suite jeté l'opprobre
sur les plans industriel parce que les
vilains lobby cachent des puces 5g dans
les rillettes de poulet pour nous forcer
nos vacciner alors oui les plats
préparés sont trop salée mais
figurez-vous qu'en france la plus grande
partie du sel qu'on consomme provient
d'abord du pae des biscottes puis de la
charcuterie des sauces et seulement
après des plats cuisinés des fromages et
des sous en résumé rien de tel qu'un bon
petit sandwich jambon et mentale
accompagné d'un potage lasagnes
surgelées
mais je m'égare pour paraphraser ce bon
vieux médecins suisses paracelse point
trop n'en faut
mais point pas assez lent faut non plus
car le sel est nécessaire à la vie sans
lui on our heads déshydratation et les
éléments chimiques qu'il contient le
chlore il sodium nous sont
indispensables
ils servent notamment à la contraction
de nos muscles à la transmission des
influx nerveux et au bon fonctionnement
de notre système immunitaire
bref comme disait frédéric françois je
ne peux pas vivre sans sel et vu qu'on
l'éliminant partie par la transpiration
et au cabinet il faut bien qu'on
compense ses pertes en en consommant du
sel car il est essentiel
sial en tout cas vous avez saisi le côté
ambivalent de la chose et bien sachez
qu'on n'est pas les seuls à grimacer
quand il ya trop de sel très peu
d'espèces aime ça mais certaines sont
sur fait une spécialité comme la
provence et les pieds paquets ou
l'auvergne et les tripots prenait d'une
alliée la saline à l'algue roses et des
étangs qui contribue à donner aux
flamands leurs couleurs chatoyantes
s'étale de supporter plus de 300 grammes
de sel par litre d'eau c'est énorme
sachant que l'eau de mer est à 35
grammes par litre et que c'est déjà
violent pour les bestioles qui vivent
cette algue est d'ailleurs la plante
principale sinon la seule qui squattent
les environnements extrêmes comme la mer
morte où les marais salants là ont fait
évaporer l'eau pour cueillir le sel ça
veut dire que dans ces endroits toute la
chaîne alimentaire dépend de cette
petite cellule rose mais à part quelques
warriors comme elle l'immense majorité
des espèces tire la tronche quand c'est
trop salée et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
salle les aliments pour les conserver
d'ailleurs ça permet de tuer les
microbes qui voudraient en faire leur
quatre heures
aux saluts belle mais qu'est-ce qui fait
la salut bah écoute il ya montée qui m'a
dit de passer du coup je possède pas et
tu peux participer à ma vidéo sur le
sable ça me fera des abonnés vu le
contexte actuel avec montée je suis pas
trop envie de me mettre mal accueillie
non mais ça va il s'en remettra je sais
pas je suis là j'ai fait le trajet en
bagnole
non ça ne changera les idées ouais mais
bon j'y connais pas grand chose mais à
ton sujet là mettant à profit sera de
façon c'est comme ça qu'on fait en
sciences je sais pas il ya le temps de
setup en plus mettre le micro tout là
bas je m'en occupe ça on fait un truc à
larache
ce sera très bien c'est beau youtube
[Musique]
pendant tout cas le sel c'est vrai que
ça fait ça fait hyper longtemps que
quand on consomme on a déjà des traces
depuis le néolithique
donc on va dire depuis 8000 avant notre
ère on a des traces d'exploitation de
celles déjà même si on a beaucoup de
mines qui se sont développées au
deuxième millénaire avant notre ère fait
le sel ça sert vraiment la conservation
des aliments
d'une part mais ça sert aussi à d'autres
choses comme par exemple la tannerie le
travail du cuir la conservation des
dépôts le sel au début c'est un petit
peu rare donc ça vaut cher puisqu'en que
c'est demander ce qu'est une vraie
utilité est donc assez rapidement le sel
va servir de monnaie d'échangé on va
échanger du sel contre autre chose
le mot salaire vient en partie de celles
parce que les soldats romains notamment
était en partie payées avec avec du sel
du coup il le sait les relativement
liées à l'économie et sa pas que durant
l'antiquité puisque durant la période
médiévale aussi philippe 6 en 1332 il va
mettre en place un truc qu'on est
nombreux à connaître même si on a des
souvenirs un peu vague de l'école c'est
la gabelle c'est à dire qu'à l'époque le
commerce du sel représente quand même
une manne financière
hyper importante pour le royaume et lui
il n'a pas envie de
laisser échapper tout se fout en dehors
du royaume donc il met en place la
gabelle qui est une taxe sur le sel est
concrètement comment ça va se mettre en
place et bah il il fait monter des
greniers un petit peu partout sur tout
le territoire des greniers qui vont
servir à stocker le ciel et les gens
vont devoir aller se servir dans ses
stocks et donc payer une taxe sur ceux
celles qu'il va récupérer avec des prix
qui sont bien évidemment contrôlé par la
couronne et que la couronne va récupérer
cet axe tout le monde l'appelle souffre
des grands privilégiés où des gens qui
ont des caractères comme les bretons 1
par exemple parce que quand un
typiquement le royaume de bretagne va se
rattacher au royaume de france en 1532
ils vont négocier tout un tas de trucs
les bretons et ce quand même et on veut
bien mais d'accord on veut quand même
des trucs et il ya notamment le fait
d'être exempté de la gabelle et ça va
produire des trucs un peu rigolo parce
que comme on le disait dans l'histoire
l'alimentation le ciel
il sert à la conservation et notamment
la conservation du beurre est ce qu'il
va se passer c'est que dans tout le
royaume
on va essayer de pu mettre de sel dans
le beurre pour éviter que le beurre soit
soit trop cher parce qu'il est taxé et
donc on va trouver d'autres alternatives
alors qu'en bretagne on est free là on
n'a pas à payer les taxes sur le sel
donc vive le beurre salé on continue à
en remettre dedans et c'est de là aussi
que vient le beurre salé bretagne 500
ans sur le sel revoir notre plan pour un
monde d'après à l'auto l'hérault pour
savoir comment résister au sel il faut
d'abord comprendre quel est son problème
et la réponse est dans la question non
pas du tout la réponse et l'osmose vous
êtes sûrement demander pourquoi le sel
donner soif
oui on s'attaque aux vrais questions ici
c'est du journalisme poil à gratter dans
cette vidéo au vitriol la lanceuse
d'alert que je suis vous apprendront que
le sel attire l'eau l'eau va toujours du
milieu le moins salée au plus à l'est ou
plutôt du milieu le plus dilué vers le
plus concentrées en soluté les solutés
c'est en gros tous les gaz liquides et
solides dissous dans notre eau et ce
phénomène qu'on observe et physique
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'osmose pour le
dire autrement les dieux de la chimie
vous vous la égaliser les concentrations
dans les deux milieux
et donc y aura plus d'eau là où il ya
plus de scènes ou plus généralement dion
salento en fait l'audi au soluté gérer
ou thuir donc si vous manger une tartine
de morue aux anchois accompagné d'un
espuma d'algues sur son lit de frites
les dix kilos de sel qui sont maintenant
en solutions dans votre sang vont
aspirer l'eau en dehors de vos cellules
les cellules vont se retrouver tout
flétri et vont vous supplier de vous
enfilez un litres de flotte pour
compenser et de ne plus jamais jamais
salle est votre plat avant le goûter
donc pour résumer le sel en excès a la
fâcheuse tendance de nous déshydraté et
c'est pareil pour tout le monde si vous
savez votre pot de fleurs le sel va
retenir l'eau du sol et c'est comme si
vous aviez téléporter votre pétunias
dans le désert plonger votre poisson
rouge dans la mer bull va se vider de
son nous attends tu lui fais quoi
maintenant c'est une expérience de
pensée on va pas vraiment faire mais si
on le faisait notre poisson d'eau douce
dans l'eau saleilles finirait tout c'est
comme une chypre alors qu'il baigne
littéralement dans l'eau c'est un peu
ironique
ouais alors t'es gentil et valentine le
prends pas mal mais je serai hyperassur
et si tu t'approches est pas du bassin
qui au fond du jardin
c'est parce que je tombe dedans
heureusement certaines bestioles et
plantons développer des innovations
brevetées soldes proof et c'est
justement d'elle qu'on va pouvoir
s'inspirer pour bâtir notre humains 2.0
du tueur fou
[Musique]
les poissons marins par exemple ont un
merveilleux mécanisme d'ossements
régulation qui comme son nom l'indiqué
permet de réguler l'osmose comme ils
sont moins salée que leur environnement
ils ont tendance à perdre de l'eau comme
notre bulle et à se faire envahir par le
sel du coup ils boivent leur race pour
contrer cette perte d'eau donc pour
répondre à cette autre question que vous
vous êtes sûrement jamais posée oui les
boissons boivent
enfin les poissons marins boivent ils
boivent beaucoup même mais le hic c'est
que cette eau est salée et oui c'est
ballot du coup il l'a filtre grâce à
leur système rénal et leurs branchies
lesquelles leur permettent de relarguer
le sel habile et en plus ils urinent
très peu pour ne pas gaspiller cette
précieuse ressource
donc quand vous dites que vous pouvez
bien faire pipi dans la mer parce que
les poissons eux ne se gênent pas sachez
qu'il vous regarde avec mépris et
constipation consternation
du coup puisque tu es là et qui m'emmène
dans ce joli cadre bucolique tu peux
m'expliquer comment ça marche les
espèces migratrices gens les saumons
comment elle passe d'un milieu marin à
un milieu d'eau douce samson mourir
ouais bah du coup les sons on s en
rivière voilà à cool abonnez vous
donc les saumons mais sans rivière donc
en eau douce où ils vont rester un à
deux ans et ses petits saumons les
appels d'état qu'on est au bout de ses
seins deux ans
une subissent une métamorphose ce qu'on
appelle la cie multiplication donc ils
deviennent des petits smolts qui choisi
ce nom
donc il ya plusieurs types de
changements qu'on peut observer chez ces
petits poissons des changements au
niveau physique donc leurs yeux vont
grossir pour s'adapter à l'obscurité
leur record va s'allonger leur peau
grasse argenté tu as aussi des
changements au niveau du comportement
donc ils sont plus sédentaires mais vont
devenir grégaire donc se re propre et un
banc et puis bah t'as des changements
physiologiques ou les mécanismes osmo
régulateurs vont s'inverser pour
s'adapter à la salinité une fois en mer
les saumons vont se diriger vers le nord
de l'océan atlantique pour manger
grossir tout ça tout ça où ils vont
rester à peu près 1 à 3 ans puis les
saumons adultes vont revenir en rivière
pour se reproduire c'est ce qu'on
appelle la migration de montaison et du
coup le saumon passe au cours de sa vie
de l'eau douce et l'eau salée re à l'eau
douce et parfois même rehausse l ere
l'eau douce du cou a expliqué comment se
passaient l'osmose en mer en rivière
basse l inverse le saumon et plus avec
son environnement dokolo entre par osmos
et le sel s'en échappent par diffusion
donc pour garder son équilibre interne
il va arrêter de boire
il va uriner beaucoup pour évacuer cet
excès d'eau et il va capter le sel et
les minéraux dont il a besoin via des
cellules dans ses branches et donc il
fait exactement l'inversé
exactement et à une méthode d'ailleurs
pour étudier la migration des poissons
qui s'appelle l'auto litho mettrie un
nom un petit peu par hasard parce que en
fait chez la plupart des poissons tas
dans l'oreille interne ce qu'on appelle
des otolithes auto oreilles littoz
pierre etc des concrétions calcaires qui
vont enregistrer la tra chimique des
autres tout au long de la vie du poisson
une espèce de boîte noire naturelles et
du coup les changements salinité
s'enregistrent sur ces otolithes et
quand tu les tu dis bah tu peux voir si
le poisson est passé d'eau salée à eau
douce tout au long de sa vie mais par
contre pour voir ça il faut que le
poisson et du coup les otolithes si on a
chez les humains aussi aussi trop cool
donc ça veut dire que si on arrive à
être résistance l on pourrait passer de
riviera mère et tous et se seraient
enregistrés dans nos oreilles ouais
c'est trop cool oui on fait ça allait on
monte une start up a laissé par ta lady
donc pour survivre dans un milieu salle
et il faut déjà pouvoir compter sur vous
vous pouvez boire abondamment et
recracher le sel par exemple par vaux
branchies comme le font les poissons
mais pour vous aider à mieux éliminer ce
poison vous pouvez vous faire pousser
des glandes à celle dans le rectum comme
les raies et les requins c'est la grande
tendance automne-hiver ces glandes
filtre l'eau de mer que le poisson aval
et elle stocke le sel moi je connais
d'autres qui respire parler qu on trouve
aussi des glandes à celle chez plein
d'autres animaux marins
et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle vous
pouvez choisir l'orifice par lequel vous
allez recracher tout ce sel par les
narines comme certains iguane qui
éternue du sel ou comme les oiseaux
leurs glandes sont situées entre les
yeux et ils excrète par les narines qui
sont sur leur bec une solution très sale
et du sérum physiologique en guise de
morve quoi et ensuite il évacue tout ça
en secouant la tête
on a tous vu ce geste caractéristiques
des mouettes sur la plage ou alors des
des albatros qui suivent indolent
compagnons de voyage le navire glissant
sur les gouffres amers
à chaque fois je le remarque depuis la
poupe de mon yacht et je me dis qu'on
apprécie pas assez les plaisirs simples
de ma vie de la vie autre option vous
pouvez pleurer du sel comme les tortues
de mer qui ont des glandes lacrymales
modifier ou comme les masculinistes sur
twitter sinon vous pouvez avoir des
glandes à celle sur la langue comme le
crocodile de mer ou sous la langue comme
les serpents de mer si en fait des
glandes salivaires modifié finalement
ces glandes acial y en a chez un bon
paquet de reptilien à votre avis
pourquoi emmanuel macron salle toujours
ses plats et s'il avait lui aussi les
glandes
donc on trouve pas mal d'espèces qui
arbore fièrement des glandes à celles
parmi les reptiles et les oiseaux et
même chez leurs lointains tontons des
tatas les dinosaures et les mosasaures
normalement filtrer l'eau de mer ça
aurait dû être le job de leurs reins
mais il s'avère que les reins des
reptiles et des oiseaux sont vraiment
pas très performant comparés à ceux des
mammifères du coup la nature a dû
trouver des astuces pour s'en sortir qui
en modifiant ses glandes lacrymales qui
en modifiant ses glandes salivaires qui
en martelant le 49-3 et ça c'est un bon
exemple de ce qu'on appelle la
convergence évolutive
ces glandes serait apparu indépendamment
chez plein d'espèces et elle leur aurait
permis de coloniser les
lieu salle et comme il présentait un
avantage évolutif ces organes auraient
été conservés par la sélection naturelle
est transmis de génération en génération
comme un précieux héritage qui vous
permet de mouches et du sel mais c'est
pas tout on trouve aussi les glandes à
celle chez les végétaux et c'est pas du
tout les mêmes structures bien sûr mais
la fonction est la même du coup si vous
préférez transpirer du sel par les ports
de vos feuilles allez voir par exemple
du côté de certaines peaux assez qu'on
appelait graminées avant comme distique
lis ce pic atteint et si les glandes
sais pas trop votre truc fait comme
certaines plantes vous pouvez décider de
stocker le sel dans des poches qu'on
appelle des vacuoles ou carrément dans
certains organes
prenez le groupe des salicornes une
plante typiques de là sans sourire c'est
comme ça qu'on appelle les prés salés en
camargue et ce moment plie de joie sans
sourire les salicornes sont des plantes
à l'ophite c'est-à-dire qu'elles
supportent des concentrations plus ou
moins élevés de sel mais elles font
aussi très bien ça pour faire une
analogie les à l'ophite ce serait les
personnes qui vont sur twitter
principalement pour s'informer et qui
slalome comme elles peuvent entre les
dramas et puis aussi celles qui vont sur
twitter rien que pour les dramas c'est
la cda l'ophite obligatoire ou
halophiles ces plantes la dépendent
carrément du sel pour vivre c'est le cas
de certaines espèces de salicorne
justement il la licorne au delà sans
sourire à une technique bien à elle elle
absorbe l'eau salée par les racines vu
qu'elle a un peu les pieds dedans et
elle conduit le sel dans des vieilles
feuilles qui ne servent plus et dont
elle se débarrasse ensuite mais
n'oubliez pas de stocker le sel dans des
poches dédié et surtout pas en vrac
en tout cas si vous êtes une plante
sinon ça va vous cramer de l'intérieur
et oui le sel est toxique pour les
végétaux mais ça aussi ses avantages de
le conserver dans ses tissus
ça nous permet de garder de l'eau avec
vous ressemble un peu à un bonhomme
michelin près mais c'est utile en cas de
disette
en tout cas c'est la stratégie des
plantes grasses qui sont un peu des
gourdes ambulante comme moi et le fait
de posséder des organes charnue gorgée
d'eau comme ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
cre a su les sens et et figurez vous que
la salicorne écrase puissante et je
trouve que ces mots traduisent très bien
la fraîcheur et le doubs fumée des
étangs bon alors c'est bien mignon là
c'est histoire de glandes d'amputations
est bonne au michelin mais il nous reste
toujours le plus gros problème à régler
cette histoire d'osmose on a vu au début
que l'eau allait toujours du milieu le
plus diluée
vers le plus concentré si vous êtes
moins salée que votre environnement vous
allez mécaniquement vous videz de votre
eau donc il faut trouver une astuce pour
rendre votre milieu intérieur autant
voire plus concentré que le milieu
extérieur pour que l'eau viennent et ne
repartent pas et là encore la nature a
des idées pour rétablir cet équilibre
osmotique vous pouvez vous mettre à
produire des petites molécules sympa
comme des sucres pour jouer les
figurants dans le décor elles sont là
pour augmenter la concentration soluté
dans votre sens mais aussi pour
neutraliser les radicaux libres liées au
stress d'un excès de sel
c'est ce que font certains microbes
comme la levure de boulanger par exemple
où cette fameuse algue rosé comme le vin
dont on a parlé au début elles
produisent du glycérol le glycérol ça un
nom barbare comme ça mais en fait c'est
un truc ultra court c'est un liquide
transparent et visqueux au goût sucré
qu'on utilise dans plein de choses des
biscuits industriels aux liquides des
cigarettes électroniques jusqu'au
suppositoire à la nitroglycérine et à
l'antigel sinon plutôt que de devenir
une usine un suppôt vous pouvez juste
oublié de sortir les poubelles c'est à
dire conserver vos déchets métaboliques
dans votre sens au lieu de les évacuer
en plus le zéro déchet c'est la mode
c'est ce que font les requins et les
raies encore eu leurs reins filtrent
l'urée comme nora nous est plutôt que
d'envoyer saturé vers la sortie il a ré
injecte dans le système
donc en gros leur sens et leur tissu on
être imbibé leur propre vie ça leur
permet tout comme le glycérol des
levures d'éviter que l'eau qu'ils
contiennent ne s'enfuient en mer comme
mon papa marins pêcheurs quand j'avais 9
ans j'ai jamais revu depuis et c'est
pour ça que si on cuisine du requin ou
de l'arrêt il faut d'abord les laisser
tremper dans du lait pendant plusieurs
heures pour les débarrasser de ce petit
goût d'ammoniac
sinon ce sera ni chrome sera juste des
lieux plusieurs heures par contre ça va
pas suffire pour laver votre honneur
parce que c'est le groupe d'animaux qui
présente le plus haut risque
d'extinction parmi tous les vertébrés et
n'oubliez pas de salé avant de servir
en résumé pour coloniser les milieux
marins la façon de ceux qui vivent déjà
vous pouvez boire beaucoup et recracher
du sel par l'orifice de votre choix
grâce à des glandes à celle en option ou
bien le stocker dans des poches dédié
mais attention montant sur la balance il
y aura une petite rétention d'eau à
prévoir vous pouvez aussi stocker le sel
dans un organe dont vous n'avez plus
l'usagé vous amputez par la suite et
n'oubliez pas de sécurité des petites
molécules sympa dans votre sang pour
rétablir les équilibres osmotique et ne
pas risquer de finir tout desséché bon
pour être tout à fait honnête avec vous
malgré tout la fois que j'ai en l'humain
augmenté je pense pas qu'on puisse
vraiment de venir sur le prouve un jour
tout cela était une vaste russe de ma
part pour vous montre
l'éventail d'adaptation que la nature à
développer pour conquérir un milieu
somme toute relativement pas très
accueillants du reste il vanta une nonne
exhaustif évidemment je vous ai pas
parlé des papilles annales des larves de
moustiques par exemple mais déjà ça
permet de voir se dessiner de belles
convergence évolutive puisqu'on retrouve
les mêmes adaptation apparu
indépendamment chez plein d'organismes
comme le glycérol chez les levures et
les allées mais soyez pas jaloux pour
autant avec ou sans glande à celle
d'andré tome vous êtes fantastique car
vous aussi en ce moment même vous osm
aurait gueulé remercier vos reins qui
régule en continu la quantité de sodium
dans votre sang pour qui on est juste ce
qu'il faut bon pas au point on pourrait
vivre dans un marais salant tel un
chèque du littoral mais au point où on
ne meurt pas après avoir englouti trois
soupire de moules frites à volonté et
c'est déjà bien mais si je vous parle de
tout ça c'est pas seulement pour vous
refourguer mon programme et vous donner
l'opportunité de financer mes prochaines
vacances à courchevel
non c'est parce qu'effectivement
changement climatique oblige notre
avenir sera bel et bien salée on n'en
prend pas plus parlé que ça et pourtant
c'est un enjeu crucial des décennies à
venir nos sols ce sale la mer monte et
infiltrent les nappes phréatiques de
plus en plus loin à l'intérieur des
terres mais pas que c'est aussi à cause
d'une irrigation mal fait par exemple si
vous arrosez trop d'un coup l'eau peut
s'évaporer et précipité les sels
minéraux qu'elle contient surtout sous
un climat aride
sans même parler du salage des routes en
hiver vous savez ce truc que les
municipalités font deux mois après le
début des chutes de neige parce qu'elles
ont été complètement prise au dépourvu
par cette mythe est aussi imprévisible
chaque année à la même date
du coup sa salle les sols et pour la
biodiversité et l'agriculture c'est pas
glop parce qu'un seul salle et devient
peu à peu stérile et qu'on peut pas
vraiment revenir en arrière après ce qui
signifie qu'on perd des terres
cultivables 20% des terres irriguées sur
la planète serait déjà touchés par ce
phénomène de salinisation soit plus de
800 millions d'hectares et ça augmente
chaque année
alors on peut imaginer utiliser des
plantes halophiles pour accumuler le sel
est justement des salles et les sols
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
phytoremédiation ou bien on trouve des
plantes cultivées qui arrive à pousser
sur ces terrains là voilà pourquoi les
chercheurs et les agronomes scrute les
plantes et les animaux de ces milieux là
si on arrivait
c'est tous leurs secrets on pourrait
essayer de sélectionner des espèces
résistantes au sel
on a même commencé à identifier des
gènes de tolérance à la salinité et
c'est pas tout en agriculture ya pas que
la plante qui importe mais aussi la
terre autour je trouve ça incroyable
on s'est rendu compte que certaines
bactéries et champignons du sol pouvait
aider les plantes à mieux tolérés ncell
notamment parce que ces microbes
régulent l'expression des gènes de la
plante pour lui faire économiser de
l'eau et pour qu'elles produisent des
hormones de croissance comme des chefs
d'orchestre discret qui se planque au
pied des végétaux c'est un peu fou comme
ça pour dire qu'il ya encore plein de
choses à découvrir et je trouve ça hyper
enthousiasmant bref l'atlantide 2.0
c'est pas pour demain mais si on fait
gaffe à irriguer correctement nos champs
on sera peut-être pas tous obligés de
manger des équidés crasseux par la
salicorne en 2000 sont bons c'est une
conclusion relativement salée mais pour
nous quitter sur une touche d'hilarité
voici le mot de la fin sans sourire
[Musique]
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
vous l'avez aimée n'hésitez pas à liker
à la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
abonnez-vous la cloche et si vous voulez
parler des reptiliens qui son
gouvernement
n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre sur le
discorde du vortex et je suis
présentement en direct sur ma chaîne
twitch sciences de comptoir dont le lien
sera en descriptions n'hésitez pas à me
rejoindre si vous regardez cette vidéo
alors qu'elle vient d'être diffusé parce
que j'y serai et comme ça on pouvoir
débriefer tout ça ensemble
venez ça va être chaud
[Musique]
écoutez je connais pas vos histoires je
sais pas pourquoi ces vacances
commencent avec une espèce de rivalités
comme ça par contre moi ce que je sais
faire c'est proposer des plans en deux
étapes staps vas-y hanté côte alors la
première étape c'est de trouver le
coupable idéal
et après on va venir lui chargé sa
barque
par contre autant pas que ce soit
quelqu'un qui puisse revenir pendant le
séjour et nous embêter oui ça s'appelle
un créatif c'était notre quatrième
colloque dans la saison précédente
et en plus il est responsable et ben
parfait là tout le sel que vous avez à
toutes les deux l'un est bien rond pas
le prendre on le met sur la barque et
puis on le transmet à la deuxième étape
qui est un barbecue avec plein de gens
et d'ailleurs marie
j'ai préparé une liste mais je décris
n'est pas si jambes tu vas les connaître
parce qu'il n'ya rien de plus fort car
réseau social qui est entièrement basé
sur la cuisson de saucisses
[Musique]